another thing you guys share was the
anxiety piece and I'd be interested
because so many people even in my life
like struggle from anxiety what are some
personal like behaviors or personal even
rituals what have you guys been able to
kind of instill in your life to help
with that I mean okay uh I still don't
have it under control or handled or
anything I started to keeping a journal
though that's helped me kind of keep
keep myself grounded and if I ever feel
myself like panicking in my room or
something I start to read it and I'm
like life is happening I don't know if
I'm if I'm feeling like if I feel like
an attack or something coming on I just
close my eyes and then it's weird but I
pretend like there's a feather there and
my breathing has to keep the feather
like floating in place yeah I do the
same thing with the bowling ball I just
try to keep the volleyball no I drink
water and workout uh-huh that definitely
helps like exercise definitely helps if
it's bad you should go to therapy I
should go to therapy I'm not what I
should or anyone should go to therapy I
don't what I should and I've never went
which is bad I know and I should because
I'm like the perfect case for that
should go to therapy but I haven't but
yeah just meditate and talk about it I
mean that was the thing that literally
saved me was going like I'm just gonna
name it I'm just gonna start talking
about it I I didn't talk about it for so
long I didn't admit it and that was sort
of the thing happened on stage I was
like man I'm really nervous to go on
stage all right I'm gonna make my whole
show about how nervous he wants to itch
and then it kind of ate itself and I was
like well this isn't really helping but
and then I tried it here yeah just get
your manager to hit you in the back as
hard yeah exact it I go yeah yeah just
yeah it's uh there's a it just put it
out in the open it I think that's the
most dangerous thing about anxiety is
that if it becomes your personal secret
you know and that's what we hope in part
the movie can do the movie can kind of
get this thing out in the open and say
this is a experi
means everyone has or not everyone has a
lot of people have and and or I think
everyone has to varying degrees but um
it it's common and it's exacerbated by
the internet and it's I think it's just
only getting more calm in this feeling I
think there's I think her generation is
gonna be a very anxious generation and
I'm sure for sure I mean I'm already
seeing it and a lot of kids I know like
it's it's not you know well I don't want
to say special because it never is but
like it's not uncommon to find anxiety
and like everyone like everyone is and I
think social media plays a part in that
honestly because everyone is just so
worried about everything all the time
and then yeah and it's it's been
directly linked to depression so it's
definitely not going anywhere
so what is your goal with the movie are
you trying to bring an awareness I mean
it's almost no no I mean we're not talk
or PSA or anything I mean really we're
just trying to make a good movie which
means that it just like yeah well thank
you just trying to engage people in a
thing make a watchable interesting thing
mmm
more than it is like some public service
it more just like express a true feeling
we have yeah and and hopefully people
can see it and either empathize whether
they're sympathize with it or hate it it
doesn't really matter you know um that
was just the goal make a good movie you
know you have ideas and themes on your
head but then when you get down to
actually making the movie it's like just
tell the story about this person